[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super-pumped to be talking about multi
agent environments and artificial
intelligence we have Toto Markov joining
us on the show hello hello thank you for
having me thank you so much for coming
on I'm really excited for this episode
there's so much to learn about this
field that's permeating into every
aspect of our lives those that don't
know toward his background he is a
machine learning researcher at open AI
with degrees from Stanford in symbolic
systems and statistics his current focus
is on multi agent environments and
transfer learning and you can find the
links in the bio below to open AI calm
as well as Twitter's open AI as well as
toter Markov's github his website there
and his linkedin profile links he can
find all those below check them out
I told her let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world right so I think
today um a lot of changes in the world
are strongly driven by emerging new
technologies like artificial
intelligence but also like genomics
software material science I think today
is particularly exciting because we are
seeing significant speed-up and
impressive new developments in some of
these fields like AI but also in things
like 3d printing and I think a lot of
the future of humanity is going to be
driven by developments in these
technologies and by how well we can use
them to improve the human condition
and how do you think we can ensure that
the technologies are used to any answer
human condition ah I think that's a hard
question it's a question a lot of
scientists think deeply about a lot of
policy people think deeply about I think
that it would require just being careful
with technologies that we're developing
while at the same time realizing that we
cannot it's not really an option to
stand still and try to bring progress to
a halt so I think doing this sort of
careful balancing between continuing to
move forward continuing to develop new
technologies while being careful about
safety considerations about being
inclusive and really thinking deeply
about the effects that the technology is
going to have on different people is the
way to go forward you know they're very
careful slow but thinking geopolitically
how to do it not
yeah but not standing still yes yes yes
okay okay okay let's get to let's get to
the journey so born in Bulgaria yes and
actually we were wondering where like
his Markov Markov chain yeah yeah
surname of her Bulgarians and so you
left at 18 to go to Stanford and that's
reduce in boxes and statistics I'm
curious who were you when you were young
that kind of like linked you into being
passionate about science and technology
ah yes so when I was in Bulgaria growing
up I had the very good fortune of going
to what's called a gymnasium which is a
specialized school for that focuses on
mathematics and Natural Science so I
went to a really great school in
Bulgaria I had the great fortune of
having really great teachers I did a lot
of contests in Bulgaria both
in math both nationally and
internationally I got some great
mentorship from the team leads for the
national math team in Bulgaria I got
some great peers great friends from that
experience and that's how I got really
passionate about math and science and
new technologies and that's also how I
decided that I wanted to study abroad
for college because a lot of other
people who were competing had done it
and they had great experience doing it
so I decided that hey I want to do that
- it seems cool and Here I am
whoa what a gymnasium is what it's
called
yes yes so this was a like a whole
height was in Middle School in high
school yes like okay yes yes the 12th
grade the 12th grade nice and powerful
teachers curriculum yes
yeah the mentorship is crucial and also
you saw some you saw people before you
going abroad and yet you were able to
also make the decisions go abroad now
when you got to Stanford and he started
surrounding yourself with other really
smartypants kids it was interesting I
think from a diversity perspective it
was much higher diversity than my peer
group in high school my peer group in
high school had a lot of people who are
extremely technically proficient in math
in physics and computer science but it
had a much smaller number of people who
would be really good at say history or
philosophy who would have really
in-depth read about it and thought about
it just because the educational system
didn't reward it as much whereas at
Stanford there was a much higher variety
in terms of people who are doing more
humanities or
artsy type of things there were more
people also who had worked on
interesting site projects like things in
robotics or small start-up ideas
type of thing at the same time I
actually found that the average or maybe
even the top 70 the top 20 percentile
people were from a purely technical
perspective in math or in physics were
not quite as good as the national team
at Bulgaria so in that sense it helped a
lot in terms of I think a lot of people
coming into Stanford have a very strong
intimidation factor of oh my god
everyone here is so good and for me it
was more like yeah people here are like
very good they're very talented they're
all smart kids but I've been in a
similar situation before with people who
are like just as good if not better
nice that's cool apply okay and then how
about then would you say that symbolic
systems and statistics are two of the
better fields to go into if you want to
go into machine learning yes I think
they're both great options for symbolic
systems so let me first talk a little
bit about what that is symbolic systems
is a program at Stanford that
encompasses several different
disciplines so we studied linguistics we
studied philosophy we studied a little
bit of neuroscience and then we studied
math and computer science so it's
similar to cognitive science degrees at
other universities but it tends to be
more technical and focuses yeah a little
bit more on the math side and on the
computer science side but at the same
time it's still very flexible and it
allows you to specialise in whatever
you're interested in so symbolic systems
it has specializations ranging from
applied logic to neuroscience to
artificial intelligence so it gives you
a really high degree of flexibility in
terms of making it what you want it to
be and that is one of the main reasons
that I was very attracted to it
flexibility got flexibility baby yes
agree and then statistics as well yes I
think that this
a lot of the theoretical models behind
machine learning and deep learning to
the extent that they exist are driven by
statistical models and statistical
thinking so I think statistics is a very
good way of approaching or getting into
machine learning on or deep learning
especially for people who are a little
bit more mathematical a little bit more
theoretical who want to build a little
bit more intuitions about ok I want to
actually know what this thing is doing
and why it's working and are a little
bit less satisfied by just okay it's not
working let me add three more layers in
my neural net and try again since they
actually understand why it's working why
it isn't working
nowhere to troubleshoot to debug this
type of stuff yes and right now there's
a relatively little like very rigorous
theoretical understanding of why and how
deep learning works there is a little
bit and it's a very active area of
research there's lots of people in math
and statistics who are starting to pay
more attention to it but I think it's a
really exciting field and I think yes
for more theoretical people who are
interested in this field statistics is a
great way to get into AI get into deep
learning and attack the problems in the
field from a bit more theoretical
approach and then so then you also spent
a good amount of time doing ei stuff
logic robotics you like climbing
philosophy these are kind of like some
of the fields that you're interested in
but you ended up doing some work in tech
and finance Bridgewater Stanford
artificial intelligence laboratory blend
oh this is all pre open AI yes and what
was kind of some of the big core
takeaways from that period for you ah
lots of different things and different
things from all the different places but
I
core takeaways where communication is
really important you should try and have
very clear lines of communication with
everyone you're working with and also
with for relationships in your life
beyond work you should strive very hard
to be comfortable giving people feedback
even if it's critical and also receiving
critical feedback from people and acting
on that and on a more practical
project-based level I think those
experience were very useful for me in
terms of picking up skills like how to
learn things on your own effectively how
to take a big vague project break it up
into bite-sized chunks and then execute
on those chunks one by one how to manage
your time well things like that yeah
okay whoa
so this is like actually quite important
to go and pick up these skill sets that
you're talking about prior to either
doing entrepreneurship or joining other
industries it's like learning about
those skills and applying them in the
rest of your life practices good very
good okay now okay open AI stuff give us
a quick the quick like mission on open
AI so opening eyes mission is to develop
artificial general intelligence so
artificial intelligence that is human
level or above in any task of economic
or intellectual interest to humans and
we want to do this in a way that's safe
and in a way that is fair such that the
benefits from this artificial general
intelligence are fairly distributed
across all of humanity and are not
overly concentrated in a certain set of
countries or a certain set of
shareholders to the exclusion of other
people
Wow yeah that's huge this see this is
why that when we were saying earlier
open AI has one of those those ethic
core ethics that is safety and fairness
yes and this is a big part of some of
the code updates that we're having is
this inclusive stakeholders yes that
this is not just for extremely wealthy
and rock it off this is for all of us to
go from triangle to circle on the planet
that decentralized yes infrastructures
that are coming in I love that part okay
now let's get into let's let's start
breaking down some of this work you guys
have been you guys have been actually
like blowing everyone's minds with with
creating right which right now are
narrow artificial intelligences that are
beating humans at what we used to think
couldn't happen dota2 yes
Starcraft these games are and here and
here we have some example videos where
we're actually gonna be talking about
how these things work and one of the
core parts is the competitive self play
component yes so competitive self play
is a key idea right now in how AI
systems especially in competitive games
like go or dota or Starcraft are
developed it was originally the first
big example of competitive self play was
alphago back in 2016 when it defeated
that the world champion Lisa DOE and
everyone was super shocked because many
people did not expect that to happen for
at least 10 years and the key idea
so alphago wasn't trained entirely with
competitive self de but a lot of it
training was self play and the key idea
is very simple the idea is that if you
have some sort of competitive two-player
or even with more than two-player game
you're just going to have the same agent
continuously play against itself and
slowly get better that way
and the reason that works is that it
provides what we call automatic
curriculum it's always at the
appropriate level where it's difficult
enough that you can learn new things but
not so hard that you just have no idea
what's going on we can't learn any
anything so if I had to draw a
comparison if you were learning to play
chess and you were a mid ranked level if
you're playing against say your
six-year-old nephew you probably
wouldn't learn that much and if you're
playing against Bobby Fischer you
probably also wouldn't learn that much
but if you're playing around someone at
your level then that's when a lot of
learning is actually going to happen and
competitive self play is one way to
induce that sort of appropriate
difficulty level where it's hard enough
that you can learn but not so hard that
you're just stuck and don't know what to
do yeah that part's critical this is
like when adults play with children and
it's not the adults bring down their
skill level so the child's children's
skill levels as the children can learn
just keep winning at about the same
skill level that they know and a little
more but the crazy thing is that you can
then do that over and over again so as
it incrementally learns it's
continuously going up one level
incremental learning times millions of
plays and this is what's crazy when we
take millions of plays that go or
Starcraft it takes us a lifetime yes but
millions of place for you is okay yes
yeah it's definitely for this type of
games especially when it can perfectly
simulate them and and where you have
access to perfectly accurate simulation
data this is extremely strong because
you can just have it play a lot and it's
still it's horribly inefficient compared
to a human like a pro like yeah like
this this probably took like hundreds of
thousands of tries
and if you had to do it you would do it
way faster and we've dota like og who
are a top-ranked world-class team they
played for maybe 10 20 or they learned
to play for 10 15 years something like
that
opening eyes bought spent forty five
thousand years which is insane I don't
know if like the total human mount of
time spent playing dota is equal to
forty five thousand years and forty five
thousand years was played in how much
time ah
that was over seven or eight months
shoving that I'm forty five thousand
years worth of gameplay yes in seven to
eight months this is why the creative
potential to learn things that even
humans haven't tested yet given the
scenarios and circumstances is just so
much higher yes and we did see that
during the matches between open era and
og we're opening I did some very unusual
strategies which no one in DotA really
does so we did like a very aggressive
game but also very aggressive use of
buybacks during the mid game which I
don't know of any other team that has
used this in the past and from looking
at interviews with og after the match
and also actually just talking with the
contractor teams that we've had that
were testing the team for us we found
that or playing against the bots really
helped them tighten up their game and
explore new things get new ideas for how
dirty they can improve their own game
yeah so I think that really also
highlights the potential for AI to act
together with humans and help them learn
and help them improve and get better at
the things that they care about you you
the the hybrid potential is yes very
very beautiful I want to ask a couple
questions on the technical side I think
it's important to at least break this
down what what are the environments
where you're where you're designing this
is this is CAD computer-aided design
ah this one I'm guessing is a reskin
version of mucho Co which is yeah mucho
Co stands for multi joint control and it
is a fairly it's a very good physics
simulator that's very popular for AI
research especially for research in
robotics because it's yeah it's a
reasonably accurate simulator of that
models lots of different real-world
physics it's not perfect clearly but it
does a very good job
it has good support and lots of
researchers really like it I like it
I think it's good and this is a physics
simulator yeah yes interesting and then
in terms of how the actual math works
behind the physics simulation component
how the designs are actually made and
how they're really quickly computing on
exactly how to in this case it's saying
if you can get the ball kick past the
goalkeeping opponent yep or in the other
one we have the sumo example where
they're trying to push each other out of
the ring yes so how is the math working
in the background where it's trying to
realize where the other object is how to
push it how is that happening right so
actually most of the math here is baked
into the simulator so that the physics
part has a lot of math in it and that
one is I actually don't know that many
details about it I've played a little
bit with the internals of mucho Coburn's
as we said it's lots of complicated math
and on the agent side
in terms of how is the
how is the agent actually learning to do
things how is it learning how to do sumo
well or how is it learning to stay
upright when it's being pushed by wind
there there is some math but actually
most of the math is we we don't
explicitly tell the agent
hey here's how you place you do sumo
well or hey here's how you stand up
right when there's winds what we do is
we just we use something called
reinforcement learning so the idea is
that when the agent is interacting with
the environment it gets a certain reward
if certain things happen so for example
in the goalkeeping task you get a reward
if you score a goal and the keeper gets
a reward if it stops the ball if it
stops a goal from being scored in the
sumo test you get a reward if you trip
the other your opponent in the wind task
you get a reward if you don't fall down
so you have these rewards and then you
have an update rule which it varies
depending on the specific algorithm it's
doing but the general idea is that you
tell your agent
hey here's how you learn based on how
you do a small learning step based on
what you did in this episode and the
reward that you got and so the basics
are somewhat simple there's still some
math involved but I think it's the math
there is relatively simple compared to
the math in the physics simulator yeah
but it's still it's the impressive part
is that it's still able to learn these
relatively complicated tasks where like
in this case it's the sumo game and the
wind and the like kicking the ball but
it can also learn extremely complicated
things it can learn how to play go it
can learn how to play DotA
at an extremely high level and those
things are something where if you try to
explicitly tell the agent hey here are
the rules by which you play go at a
world-class level here are the rules by
which you play dota at a world-class
level you would never be able to do that
just humans don't know how to do that on
explicit level if you ask Lisa Doh hey
why's that move good he can point at
some general insights but it's not
something where you can write a
checklist and then by following the
checklist you can play go well
it relies a lot on intuition and
implicit representations and I think
it's very impressive that this type of
simple learning rules can learn these
very complicated intuitions these very
complicated internal representations so
you can create an aware character agent
in the physics simulator and then as
they do something like prevent this
person from running past that line that
they get rewarded and they know that
then that is a behavior that I should
continue yes very similar to us as
agents in this world as well when we do
something like exercise or choose a
healthy food option or when we achieve a
bunch of goals that we have set for
ourselves we get rewarded and so these
is yeah so yeah any we'll get to that
question at the very end of this okay
let's did we we did the wind attack one
two Ron did we do the second one two
this is the wind or this is this is the
wind attack right yes yeah okay so then
so this is this is putting a a and
you're putting a vector of of wind at
like a certain degree of strength yes
and asking the agent to stay on the
similar platform yes so the interesting
part about this one is that actually
this agent that's here right now is the
same agent that was playing sumo before
so the agent that was played the
playing sumo we took it out and we
placed it in this new environment with
wind and it's never seen wind before and
we actually didn't allow it to Train we
told it here is this new environment
here's this new thing that you have no
idea what it is you've never seen it
before
figure it out and the thing that we like
is that actually it's reasonably good at
figuring it out
it's doink reasonable things it has this
squatting stance it's kind of stable
it's trying to stay in the center and
this is without any training on a new
environment that it hasn't seen before
so this is an example of what we call
transfer or transfer learning where
things that you have learned in one
environment that you've trained in then
transfer in a different environment with
somewhat different dynamics so as we see
here it turns out that the things that
you learn for staying upright in sumo
for not getting tripped over they also
help you if you don't have another
opponent but if you have wings that you
need to deal with
that's so cool this is like the kind of
the first incremental steps towards
trying to generalize yeah narrowing
exactly yeah that's beautiful beautiful
example okay and then the next one is
this the you guys had it what was it an
ant a bug and a spider
well yeah two legs four legs and six
legs all right Julius we started for
like six legs and eight legs yes yes so
this work was something done by my team
moti at the moti agent team at open AI I
think about a year or two years ago
around that time frame and the idea here
is that you have two different
algorithms one is just a regular deep
reinforcement learning algorithm and the
other is metal learning algorithm which
can learn and adapt based on within an
episode what the other agent is doing so
initially this was for this work we had
a population of these different
algorithms who are also controlling
these different robots so the foreleg
drag leg robot we call it an ant the six
legs green robot we call it a bug and
there was also a eight-legged robot that
was called a spider so the bug is the
strongest one in terms of physical
strength so things like how much force
can apply on your joints and the spider
was the weakest one and so we ran these
multiple algorithms with running on
multiple robots on robots in tournament
league where we ran evolution on that
league so agents and algorithms that
when got to survive and replicate and
agents and algorithms that lost would
continue would be pruned and eliminate
it
that's the fifth asset round if you want
to bring that one up so that shows like
you were just describing that over time
you can actually see which agents are
the winners in all of these different
simulations that occur yeah and over
time one of the models beats out the
other ones and that's the yeah called
the meta meadow a model agnostic meta
learning yes algorithm yep exactly so we
see here that spiders don't do as well
because they're weak but also meta
learning the meta learning algorithm
does better than the regular algorithm
and also there's a difference here in
terms of our model architecture versus
like whether the architecture of the
neural net you're using is house aware
of is aware of time of what's happened
during the wrestling before or whether
it just treats every time step
individually so being aware of time also
helps a lot and agents who are aware of
time end up doing much better in this
tournament
Maria's something that was interesting
here that we thought was important is
that even with the aunt a weaker agent
the meta learning algorithm was still
stronger and better by a bug controlled
by a regular reinforcement learning
algorithm and so yes the broad idea
behind meta learning algorithms is that
they're learning how to learn they can
learn how to do different tasks quickly
they can adapt to new circumstances
quickly and this was one small but I
think still important example of why
this matters and how this helps you
perform better in competition with other
agents but also potentially on other
tasks that you might care about versus a
reinforcement learning first well meta
learning is still technically
technically a reinforcement learning
algorithm but it's a specific approach
to it which has advantages over regular
algorithms it also has some
disadvantages they can sometimes be
slightly less stable it can be hard to
get them to work but I think it's an
exciting area of research within
reinforcement learning so the edge of
knowledge has been pushed in
reinforcement learning and now we're
going even further and seeing which
algorithms of reinforcement learning are
good at whichever tasks within that
within that field yes or we're thinking
about how it usually most algorithms of
reinforcement learning they're good for
many different tasks so the same
algorithm that plays dota
it can also learn to use a robotic hand
to manipulate a cube
mm-hm and it has no idea what
environment it's working that's the same
reinforcement learning algorithm yes
same one that's so that so then that
doesn't generalize ah sort of so it's
not the same weight it's not the same
like the motto itself is the learned
model is different but if you start from
a novel model the same algorithm that
learns how to play Delta it can also
learn how to control the robotic hand
and it assigns weights to variables over
time yes
based on current Awards yes okay yeah
there was there was some there was an
interesting component to this which was
that at some point you actually this is
it's right here that rewards for
behaviors that aid exploration like
standing and moving forward which are
eventually anneal to zero in favor of
being rewarded for just winning yeah
losing I thought that part was really
interesting so that's first it's like
you get rewarded for doing these
interesting even just standing up being
exploring yes and then that goes to zero
because the most important reward is
whether or not you can win the game of
sumo pushing the other thing off yes so
yeah this is an example of something
that is a hard problem in reinforcement
learning that is also an active area of
research which is how to solve
exploration problem and also sparse
versus dense rewards which is one
approach to it so in general in
reinforcement learning we say that you
have a sparse reward if the reward that
you're getting is relatively rare so say
you only win it you only get rewards
once you defeat the other agent in sumo
and we say that you're getting dense
rewards if you're getting what reward
much more frequently like for example
reward based on or if you up right if
you're still upright you're getting
reward and there is a trade-off between
those two things
sparse rewards help you be much more
accurate in terms of targeting exactly
the behavior that you want to learn like
if you're playing chess you care about
checkmate
the other the opponent you don't
necessarily care what type of opening
you're playing or mid game as long as
you can checkmate your opponent but when
the reward is sparse that makes it
harder for the agent to learn because in
the beginning it's kind of doing random
things and if it's hard to get the
reward
it may never figure out what is expected
of it so if I were to draw a parallel
here like if you wanted to like if you
had a dog and you wanted to train it to
do tricks you would not start with very
complicated things because it would it
would never be getting rewards and you
could never figure out what it needs to
do we start with fetch me orange juice
exactly so you want to start robot or
something like yeah you start with
simple things and you gradually increase
the complexity and this is also what we
did in the sumo game where we started
with simple things like okay stay
upright move towards the center of the
room but eventually we wanted to
actually do the thing which we care
about which is we need sumo so as time
progresses we start rewarding it less
for the simple things and more for the
actual victory and at the end we're only
rewarding it for the actual victory Wow
okay so you start with the dense rewards
and then over time the rewards become
sparse yes wow that's that's a really
cool component to reinforcement learning
Wow
competitive self play is freaking crazy
this look at this it's like running you
know look at this it's just it's it's
nuts how quickly these agents can learn
to be so much at their peak at their
absolute best and the applicability zuv
this are also into like all of the like
automobile and like manufacturing and
airline and even so many other
simulations and biotech in other fields
just like how do you optimize for a
given variable like constraints how do
you optimize like you can literally test
like a part on a vehicle or
a hundred thousand miles and see how
well it does stuff like that yes though
actually that's another open research
problem in reinforcement learning that's
very important and the people are very
interested in solving in that right now
Jarro
actually hasn't been applied directly in
the real world that much and the reason
is that it is extremely data hungry
so it requires these simulations but a
lot of simulations they are they don't
perfectly match the real world and if
you directly training simulation and
then try to transfer in the real world
often time your thing is just not going
to work because the real world is
different there is a bunch of things
happening there that are not in your
simulation and this is holes in the road
or something yes so this is called the
sim to Rio transfer problem and it's a
very active area of research in robotics
people are super excited about it lots
of smart people are thinking very deeply
about it and they know that the name of
it is again seem too real simulations to
real problems whoa that's a good one too
the sim to real problem simulation to
reality problem yes okay um let's go
into our the neural mmm oh wow okay so
mm Oh a massive multiplayer online an
RPG role-playing games usually how we
see these things like the world of
warcraft of and the grand theft auto
multiplayer sam big sandbox games these
types of things and this is crazy
because you have you're simulating
agents that are playing here and this is
a 128 concurrent yes it's playing over a
hundred concurrent servers running 128
each ish or anywhere variant and then a
hundred million lifetimes when I was
reading this I was like this is nuts
ok so yeah so neural mmm oh Jesus
yes so neural MMO
is a project that an intern on the
multi-agent team Joseph Suarez he worked
over on this over the summer of 2018 and
so this ties in the broader mission of
the multi agent team where the multi
agent team is interested or we believe
that our complex environments with
large-scale multi agent interaction lead
to the emergence of complex skills
complex behavior and that also this
behavior is robust and generalizable so
it's useful in many interesting cool
tasks outside of the original
environment that you're training with so
neural MMO was kind of like a proof of
concept for this exact idea where we
wanted to test out a relatively simple
environment with simple dynamics and see
oh if we have a massive number of agents
interacting here are we going to see
cool stuff happening and we do see some
pretty interesting things like a lot of
camping around the edge so much camping
yeah but also exploration into the
Middle's and yes so some really cool
things that I think for me were possibly
the main takeaways from this work is
that one agents which are trained with a
larger numbers a larger number of other
agents also to explain a bit how the
game works it's relatively simple we
have all of these agents they're walking
around this map they're trying to forage
for food and they can also fight with
each other and so we see even from this
simple of an environment with a large
amount of Ron go ahead and pull up the
seventh one asset as well they'll also
help you with this yet part of the
description yeah yeah so you have the
agents you can see them fighting here
and also I think there's food items that
are lying around that they're trying to
forage
and um you see we see some really
interesting behavior some really
interesting things happening even from a
relatively simple environment like this
so one important thing that we see is if
you're an agent that were trained in a
competing with a large population you
end up being roughly stronger somewhat
stronger so if you are trained during
your life with a hundred other agents
and then you're putting a server with
agents that in their life were trained
with ten other agents on their map then
you end up being stronger and you're
able to out-compete them if you are
trained with more other agents you end
up exploring more you walk around the
map more you're slightly better at
foraging and a third thing that is some
what we did it is also that um when you
train different subpopulations of agents
you see these geographical niches form
where each sub population like certain
parts of the map and kind of stays there
and tries not to walk into other pocket
other subpopulations niches so that it
doesn't have to fight with them whereas
if you only have one sub population it
tends to roam more widely and there are
no individual niches that form whoa so
so each one of the the characters have
the they have they're trying to weigh
out how close they want to be to other
characters because then they can throw
those items to take each other's health
bars down yes also they have to forage
for nutrients on your map and so they're
trying to balance all these things out a
lot or you know hang out by the like in
the center you have oh there's a larger
surface area around the around the
diameter of the to be attacked and so
like that's why some hang out around the
edge because there's only 180 degree
versus 360 etc yes sir
this is so these are some of like these
when you when you compete on this map
with the like say 128 of these and then
you become the best here then you can
moved up to where all of the other bests
all the other servers were competing
against each other ah I'm not sure if we
did it we might have done this but
something that we did do was we took
some agents that competed over 128 we
took some agents that competed with 64
we took some agents that competed with
32
we took some agents that compared to 16
and then like we put them all together
and we said fight we want to see who's
the best and it turns out that we do see
somewhat qualitatively different
behavior where in general agents that
were trained with more other agents end
up performing better and also may be a
component of this we're not sure if this
is a causal factor but one other thing
that they do is they just explore more
they roam around the map a little bit
more whereas agents that were trained
with a smaller number of other agents
they tend to hang out more closer to the
initial spots that they started that
they were spawned in and they don't move
as much and that may have to do with how
on the 128 scale that there's just so
many more pieces of info
not of knowledge to gain about how to
play at the best level versus if you're
only playing against 12 or 24 ah
eventually yeah I think it has to do
with the fact that there's just more
competition in the 128 so you need to
roam further in order to like not be
fighting all the time and in order to
avoid this type of extensive fighting
whereas with 16 you can move five steps
and you're fine so it's the same size to
Reyes it's the same size because if the
train doesn't scale that makes sense yes
okay okay okay because you can more
freely walk around you end up combating
less and young yeah okay okay you
okay and then yeah that last the last
one Ronnie so this one shows then how
they move on the terrains this image yes
and so if this is center one is when
there's only one agent yes so this is an
image that illustrates the one about
niche speciation that I was talking
about so when you only have one species
like in the center image you end up with
just one are relatively like big piece
of the map that the agents like to hang
out in and there is no um there kind of
universe a uniformly distributed across
this like this red stripe here whereas
when you have more species so when you
have eight species like in the left
image the different colors are the
different subpopulations and you see how
the different subpopulations end up
liking different pieces of the map and
they tend to hang out in there in the
same area as other as other agents
within their sub population and they
don't intersect that much with agents
from other subpopulations and we think
that this is mostly driven by just
avoiding needless fighting but we think
that it's also an interesting toy
proof-of-concept for specialization and
niche formation emerging as a part of
this multi agent interaction and we hope
that in the future with more complicated
environments we are going to see more
interesting specialization more
interesting mesh formation so we're
we're relatively happy and this result
makes us somewhat optimistic that we are
going to see that in a more complicated
environment
and this is gonna lead us to the
question that we must ask now are we
already in one of these massive
multiplayer online role-playing game
environments maybe if we are there
haven't been any very direct signs of it
I think that the counter question I like
to ask to that is if you knew that you
were in a simulation for sure or if you
knew that for sure you were not in the
simulation would that change your life
in any way would it change the actions
that you take on a day to day basis
good counter questions thoughts change
Rollins how to change it I don't [ __ ]
around now that's all period no fear I
call it like I see it
I stand corrected when I'm corrected I
live my life I try to stand up for the
oppressed there's something among us
that wants to control us and they can go
[ __ ] themselves
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so so the behavior hasn't had
did change it did change once you once
you learned well at first it was don't
get me wrong it was frightening when you
when you were aware that there's
something much larger than all of us
trying to work through us to manipulate
us to control us to do its will nothing
less than slavery all across the boards
and now that the most intelligent of us
have realized that geez something's
trying to enslave us and you know let's
let's let's let's let's try to beat it
and let's try to see us speak out
against it and then when we do that then
we become enslaved as well you know it's
looking for just ignorant people that
speak confidently of [ __ ] they know
nothing about so this is the something
beyond the three dimensional realities
taking it oh yeah multi get mad
way beyond 3d we if something
multi-dimensional comes in through earth
yeah and through us if we allow it and
then and then if and then so this is the
realization then that Ron is talking
about and toters who questioned me seems
like it was maybe somewhat I think
related but also like in terms of this
already being a simulation in terms of
this already being a massive multiplayer
online role-playing wait we're cracking
the code we're happen we're hacking it
and we're doing it to the best for
humanity all of us collectively Ron and
I about them maybe a month ago or so
we're just talking about as we continue
to make these MMORPG simulations
ourselves we gain a better understanding
of how we could have potentially already
be in one that is being manipulated by
the creators of it so that's why once
you make really complex simulations
using super intelligences it's easier
for us to look in the mirror and realize
well how is what is that already yeah so
these types of things it's very hard to
yeah it's very abstract we're still far
away from it all that stuff but yeah
they don't like me talking like I just
talk to you there they get really upset
if I go to dead in the street later on
today you know why there is also an
interesting question around agency in
that I think if you're thinking about a
simulation it's um usually I think it
implies that whoever is running it is I
think it's in a sense anthropomorphize
is them or it assumes that they have a
conscious experience or a certain set of
goals and it's not it seems possible
that you might have like there are ways
that the world might be where like what
we experience is kind of like a
simulation but there is no one
necessarily running it or the thing
running it is closer to a natural
process or a force of nature
rather than
an agent that has conscious experience
and I think that kind of blurs the lines
and creates a weird middle ground where
um it's unclear if that's what's
happening is that does that still count
as a simulation or is it meaningfully
different than this being the true
reality so in that sense I think there's
lots of interesting potential middle
ground version which would be cool to
explore yeah yeah
the the the anthropomorphizing or not of
yet of the of what is creating
potentially the profit the simulation
now what do you think happens pre-birth
and post-death um hmm probably nothing
or outcomes raiser would completely
probably nothing okay the Occam's razor
answer okay and then what do you think's
the most beautiful thing in the world
hmm the most beautiful thing in the
world humanity
tell us more why
the most beautiful thing in the world
for me is humanity and I like humanity
because well I'm biased party but there
is something aesthetically pleasing in a
sense or just the storyline of being
confused apes stuck on a rock floating
through space but still trying to do
interesting things with your existence I
think is cool and it's kind of a rooting
for the underdog vibe the world is big
and complicated and not very nice or
gentle but Humanity is still trying to
stick it out and flourish so rooting for
the underdog I love it we find ourselves
as stewards of earth good luck see if
you can handle it can you all play
together basically well yeah yeah that's
good yes it is very beautiful it is it
is so no this has been such an
interesting episode thank you thank you
for coming on and teaching thank you for
hosting me we are very grateful it's
been such a pleasure holy cow that was
super fun I mean there's just so much to
still understand about multi-agent
environments about competitive self play
neural mmo's like all the stuff that's
that you guys are doing everyone thank
you so much for tuning in we would love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below in the episode I got the links
below to open AI calm the Twitter for
open day I also told ours links and his
LinkedIn profile check all that out and
go and talk to more people your friends
your co-workers people online on social
media about things like multi-agent
environments competitive self play
neural mmo's and go and and share more
of the questions around these concepts
and go and talk to more people about
them also huge shout out to Ron Vargas
for producing and directing thank you
very much Ron and we really appreciate
it and we did pretty well with all those
videos good job round proud of us and
support the artists entrepreneurs the
organizations around the world that you
believe in support simulation our links
are below help us grow and prosper
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
[Music]